me pose souvent science et la religion
et on prend souvent galilée comme le
symbole de celui qui défend la science
contre la religion et je pense que c'est
très très très faux de dire cela s'il
faut opposer galilée à quelqu'un ou
quelque chose je pense que ce n'est pas
du tout à leur religion mais à aristote
en fait je pense qu'on peut dire que
galilée et celui qui a tué
aristote enfin papa tu es au sens tu à
tuer pour de vrai jusqu'à trois
restantes est mort d'évident galilée
mais bon vous voyez ce que je veux dire
en fait quelle idée quand il était jeune
il voulait devenir prêtre
finalement elle s'est dirigée vers des
études de médecine à l'université de
pise qui n'a pas trop aimé notamment
parce qu'ils avaient l'impression que
les jésuites c'est-à-dire un ordre
religieux qui était à rome qui était
catholique
les jésuites contrôle etc ont totalement
le contenu des cours réguliers n'était
pas content avec ce continue des cours
du coup il a arrêté ses études de
médecine et il a fait plutôt des études
en dessin et en mathématiques les
dessins lui sera d'ailleurs très utile
quand il fera de l'astronomie
puisque mon tout ce qu'il voulait
c'était à travers une lunette il n'avait
pas d'appareil photo comprendre les
images des prix ils devaient dessiner à
chaque fois et heureusement qu'il
dessinait bien sinon il aurait été
incapable de dire de parfaitement aux
présenter ce qu'il a vu mais bien sûr ce
qui aura le plus d'importance ce sont
plutôt ses études en mathématiques
puisque le génie de galilée fut de
mathématisée sa compréhension de
du monde autour de lui et puis bien sûr
il ya cette fameuse citation où il dit
que les lois de la nature sont écrites
en langage mathématique
un exemple précoce de cette
mathématisation du monde autour de lui
donc selon la légende il était dans une
église quand il vu un chandelier aussi
se balancer comme ça et là il s'est mis
à mesurer la période de six séries
d'oscillations c'est à dire le temps
qu'il faut pour que le chandelier fasse
un aller retour il la mesure est donc si
mon anecdote avec un pou parce que bon
bah je n'avais pas de s'habiller sous la
marque je sais pas mais il est là mais
on reste avec son pouf qu'il a fait une
découverte assez fort à mon vol comme
vraiment remarquable savoir le fait que
la période d'oscillations d'un
chandelier ne dépend pas de la forme du
fonds d'heuliez ont fait de plus ont
remplacé le chandelier par une pomme ou
pas pendus ce que tu veux ce que vous
voulez ça ne dépend pas non plus des
matériaux ça ne dépend pas non plus de
la hauteur de situation pour sas pas
tout à fait vrai c'est quasiment vrai et
en utilisant les mathématiques galilée
va même découvrir que cette période
d'oscillations est proportionnelle au
carré de la longueur du fil qu'on a
utilisé ça c'est vraiment remarquable
c'est quand même au coeur de tous nos
instruments de mesures qui seront
utilisés pour les siècles qui vont
suivre
monstrueux mais ceci dit je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire que galilée est un
grand mathématicien en fait je ne
connais pas de théorèmes au nom de
galilée c'est quand même une
ligne qui manque à son cv que je puisse
considérer qu'il ya les génies parfait
qui lui manquait quand même un théorème
mathématique
je pense qu'il est super important de
comprendre un peu ce background
concernant cette approche très
mathématique de galilée de la physique
de la compréhension du monde autour de
lui pour voir pourquoi il a clashé avec
talent les jésuites qui eux se reposer
plutôt sur la lecture de textes anciens
notamment ceux d'aristote et du coup on
peut vraiment dire que le conflit dans
lequel s'engage petit à petit kelly est
un conflit ouvert contre aristote et
pour le coup c'est vraiment contre
aristote et pas contre l'église puisque
galilée et catholique
il va rester catholique toute sa vie il
va même envoyé ses filles au couvent
pour faut dire que galilée avait deux
filles et un fils qui étaient tous
illégitime mais bon à l'époque ce
n'était pas si pas catholique puisque
même certains pape avait des fils
légitime d'ailleurs gallier est très
pote avec le futur pape de l'époque ça
va devenir important pour la suite de
l'histoire
alors si galilée est devenu petit le
titre est anti aristotélicien c'est
entre autres à cause de son invention du
télescope
donc ça c'est vraiment une invention
géniale de belle-ile et réinventer
mionet quoi toutefois lui les lunettes
de gagner et avec cette invention de
lunettes il va se faire des couilles en
or et une réputation énorme puisqu'il va
revendre ça aux militaires qui vont
profiter de cet appareil pour surveiller
l'horizon et mieux voir les ennemis qui
approche plus les compter tous à lui
bien sûr de façon encore plus important
auquel il est venu y ait cette lunette
pour observer le cosmos et en
particulier à faire plein de découvertes
qui veulent être le premier à faire
notamment il va voir des tâches
sombre sur la lune il valoir que la lune
est en fait pas parfaite comme gates
comme aristote avait dit mais la lune en
fait fait de montagny de creux de vale a
même mesuré foot estimer la taille de
ces montagnes et ça surtout ça va semer
le doute sur tout ce que dit aristote du
coup disent que si c'est eux que à reste
à 10 sur la lune mais il faut bas
qu'est-ce qu'il a dû devrait douter de
tout à partir de ce moment là avec 7
minutes il va aussi observer jupiter et
va voir que le jupiter à des lunes comme
on dit à paris dans l'épisode ton
épisodes précédents et il va voir que
saturne a des oreilles vont bien sûr
c'est pas les oreilles de saturne qui va
voir mais c'est son anneau sur avec la
résolution qu'ils avaient à l'époque et
du mal à bien voir c'est à nous il va
aussi voir des taches solaires sur le
soleil données représentent les soleils
un truc qui bouge beaucoup du monde
d'être encore une fois parfait ils
peuvent aussi observé venus et voir que
les ombres qui se forme sur vénus ce qui
va l'amener à conclure que vénus doit
parfois être plus loin que le soleil de
la terre et parfois plus près et ça
c'est pas très consistant avec le wydad
géocentrique donc ce que je pense
important à retirer de tout ça c'est que
galilée va faire des découvertes en
observant des choses qui n'ont jamais
été observée avant qu'ils remettent pas
mal de doutes
aristote et ça ça va l'amener à aller
plus loin et à contredire plus
fondamentalement aristote sur des lois
physiques
bien sûr il ya la loi de la chute des
corps dont on a déjà parlé dans un
épisode précédent qui lie le faire des
expériences qui semblait indiquer que la
loi d'aristote n'est pas si bonne que ça
et puis surtout il veut faire une
expérience de pensée qui va prouver une
fois pour toutes que ce que dit aristote
ne peut pas être voix et donc forcément
faux et là il a prouvé mathématiquement
à linz après de santé en mathématiques
que la loi de d'aristote et
inconsistante et donc forcément fausse
autre chose qui va faire qu'il valait
vraiment le contre de la physique la
rester poli sienne c'est qui va postuler
le principe de relativité qui dit
mouvement et comme rien de parler aussi
dans un épisode précédent en particulier
si vous jetez un ballon duo damas le
ballon va tomber au pied du mât en
particulier s'il va rester sur le bateau
il va rester au même endroit même si le
bateau avance et on particulier il va
pas rester immobile ou veux pas chercher
à être immobile contrairement à ce que
dit la loi d'aristote qui dit que les
objets chercheurs et très dans un état
naturel et l'état national et l'état de
repos le plus proche possible sauf que
la terre est ce que je trouve vraiment
amusant dans cette zone marque c'est que
galiev a en fait utilisé un raisonnement
très platonicien dire qu'il va imaginer
dans chaque fois des idées
la thématique ou des principes éthiques
qui sont vachement élégant vachement
beau vachement séduisant
mathématiquement notamment achement
mathématisation mais qui vont elles pas
mal à l'encontre des observations si
vous faites l'expérience de la chute des
corps de très trop souhaité deux objets
du haut de la tour de pise
vous allez voir que la loi de la chute
des corps de galilée n'est pas
satisfaite si vous voulez c'est vraiment
tomber la balle du haut d'un mât d'un
bateau qui va vraiment très vite vous
allez voir pas tomber exactement au pied
du mur du vent si vous vous enfermez
dans la cale d'un bateau qui avance à
vitesse constante ou les seins de savoir
que le bateau avance parce qu'ils
tombaient un petit peu et du coup on
fait tout sous ses principes
galileo ils sont pas vérifiables par
expérience ils sont souvent faux en fait
en pratique mais dans le monde parfait
des idées de la physique mathématique
comme on l'appellera aujourd'hui la
physique théorique
il va ils sont vrais est ce qu'il le
pari assez floue de galilée c'est de
supposer que pour comprendre le monde la
meilleure façon de comprendre le monde
sait d'abstraire plein de choses de la
réalité et frottement de l'air le fait
que m tanguay tout ça et de et de
raisonner sur un modèle idéalisé de tout
ça modèle platonicien dont on suppose
qu'il est vrai même s'il a fait aucun
pendant dans la réalité parce que
toujours c'est frottement de l'air où
vous pouvez toujours des imperfections
en réalité mais bizarrement ce monde
idéalisé ça c'est vraiment le pari fou
de galilée ce monde idéalisé théorique
tout ça il va nous permettre de bien
mieux comprendre la réalité
que si on avait cherché à toujours
rester dans le monde de la réalité
c'est un peu dans le pari fou de galilée
et c'est un pas extrêmement platonicien
puisque le monde des idées ça c'est très
platonicien mort bien sûr dans cette
histoire c'est que platon était le
maître de d'aristote du coup ils
utilisent les maîtres d'aristote pour
réfuter aristote et en particulier ce
que j'aimerais attirer de tout ça c'est
que galilée n'est absolument pas le père
de la méthode scientifique elle concerne
aujourd'hui par je prends une minimiser
ses contributions en fait il a fait un
truc génial aussi d'un point de vue
expériences et il peut créer
l'expérience scientifique
l'idée de l'expérience scientifique
c'est justement d'abstraire plein de
choses pour contrôler au maximum ce que
l'on fait et essayer d'enlever ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des facteurs de
confusion qui présentait frottement de
l'air des choses comme ça qui vient
perturber l'analyse idéalisé qu'on veut
faire donc oui je pense que on peut dire
que galilée le père d l'expérience
scientifique mais par contre la méthode
scientifique ça va pas vraiment tout cas
pas telle qu'elle est enseignée
nous avons l'exemple de sas l'exemple
démarré parce que gagner pour prouver
l'héliocentrisme ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il a essayé d'expliquer les marais à
l'aide du mouvement de rotation de la
terre sur lui-même et autour du soleil
donc c'est lui a fait une toute une
théorie et le problème de cette théorie
c'est qu'elle prédisait qu'il n'y avait
qu'une seule marée par jour ce qui la
fout mal puisque les marins de l'époque
avait bien vu qu'ils étaient deux marées
par jour du coup c'est une théorie qui
est contredite par l'observation du coup
devrait la rejeter mais gagner ne
rejette pas il dit que c'est l'argument
qui prouve le jeu l'héliocentrisme cette
salle c'est amusant donc ça va à
l'encontre de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la méthode scientifique mais j'ai envie
de dire que c'est pas si étrange que ça
en tout cas je pense qu'il faut voyez
pas autant de raisons de l'accabler pour
ça donc j'ai pas lu le truc où je sais
pas à quel point on peut vraiment
l'accabler pour ça mais finalement c'est
pas si différent de toutes les
réflexions qu'il a faite par rapport au
principe de relativité
à la loi de la chute des corps galilée
souvent aller à l'encontre des
observations parce qu'il a souvent
considéré que dans la réalité il y avait
des éléments de réalité qui venait
perturber dont ils et alizée des idées
des théories qui développait en revanche
considéré que ceci est l'argument
inclusif pour prouver le livre centrisme
encore une fois je n'ai pas lu je ne
peux pas vraiment joué mais nous semble
que c'est quand même un peu prétentieux
de sa part est en fait une marque de
fabrique de galilée en temps en temps
des experts par les enseignants pas bien
sûr c'est l'arrogance de galilée gamme
il était en fait quelqu'un d'extrêmement
arrogant il y avait de bonnes raisons
d'être arrogant enfin tout cas son
historique explique son arrogance
puisqu'il a prouvé maintes et maintes
fois que aristote le plus grand penseur
de tous les temps selon tout le monde à
cette époque il l'avait prouvé maintes
et maintes fois qu'aristote c'était
forcément tromper parce que sa théorie
et et inconsistante pire quelque chose
pour vous montrer l'arrogance de delhi
les il ya des débats sur les comètes à
l'époque des explications sur les
pommettes et des créations qui était pas
très bonne des levés avec fait un
bouquin pour critiquer c'est ses
explications des comètes il a proposé
des explications qui n'étaient pas
bonnes mais surtout il a lancé des
attaques gratuites dans ce google plus
il moqué de gens qui n'avaient jamais
rien dit sur les comètes
mais surtout il l'envoie en venir
vraiment à sa condamnation par
l'acquisition mais surtout donc ils
avaient demandé l'autorisation de son
pote qu'il était devenu pape à ce
moment-là l'autorisation d'écrire un
bouquin sur le débat entre lio centrisme
et loge le centrisme et le peuple lui
avais bien dit ok mais dit bien que
l'égocentrisme c'est juste une théorie
plus fait gaffe passe bien le pour et le
contre
enfin soit 6 me quand on approche des
recommandations extrêmement au sens
électrique scientifique pour beaucoup il
y alliez va pas faire ça il va prendre
totalement partie dans ce budget nous
attendons donc la partie sur les marais
qui en plus n'est pas
vraiment au grain mais pire que ça dans
ce bouquin où il va défendre à fond les
lots centrisme
il va faire un dialogue il va imaginer
un dialogue entre deux personnes lui qui
va être quelqu'un qui défend lui au
centrisme qui sera du coup je mens
galilée où on copernic et puis un autre
qui l'appelle simplicio qui veulent être
idiot naïf et tout ça et qui va
représenter les idées de l'église et qui
va sembler surtout incarner le pape et à
sa force c'est la très très mal
ça donne vraiment l'impression qu'ils ce
pays
la gueule du pape dans un bouquin public
et du coup bas il va prendre cher
du coup ça va prendre ça va devenir une
bataille d'ego parce que du coup il va
aussi se moquer ouvertement de tous ceux
qui ont dépensé aristotélicienne c'est à
dire tout le monde du coup c'est pas si
surprenante que l'inquisition a été
assez dur avec lui ceci dit
l'inquisition a des arguments mais
merveilleux enfin on dit les arguments
de l'acquisition est qu ici on utilise
l'argument de la parallaxe stellaire le
fait que ce que dit kelly les ne peut
être me coran de théorie et pao rendent
de fait contrairement à ce que galilée
sous-entendant ce bouquin tout ça c'est
vraiment pertinents c'est vraiment très
très pertinent ce que livre qui dit sûr
à ce moment là si vous dis tout ça c'est
pour vous montrer que gagner n'était pas
absolument pas dans une guerre contre
l'église mais plutôt dans des guerres
d'ego cabinet avait plein de gens et
puis ces gens là avaient beaucoup de
pouvoir du coup il a pris cher en
français il se passe est normal et tout
s'explique par des guerres d'ego et des
relations humaines et aient envie
d'extrapoler tout ça au monde
d'aujourd'hui du monde peut en débattre
ce que je veux dire ici c'est pas du
tout gravé dans le marbre pas du tout
si une opinion personnelle sur le moment
et ça peut être largement remise en
cause mais il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
le débat enfin les problèmes de société
qu'on a n'ont rien à voir avec les
religions mais comme la religion ça
attire l'attention des gens si je dis le
mot musulman la tournée commence à se
dire mais qu'est ce que je vais dire
ensuite sur les musulmans
bah c'est tentant d'utiliser ce genre de
notions pour expliquer des événements
aujourd'hui alors que très souvent prius
a fallu un panier pas de viande bien
manière c'est tentant d'utiliser la
religion pour expliquer ce qui arrive et
la galilée par qu'on fait y'a pas mieux
ce qui arrivait à un gay blessé juste
une histoire d'ego juste que j'ai su ce
que galilée avait un melon énorme qui
l'arrosait ridiculiser en public tout un
tas de personnes très importantes
du coup il y en a pris plein la gueule
pour ça pas parce qu'il est anti
religieux d'ailleurs ils étaient pas en
théorie ge était catholique